yeah just I've like like it's some guy I
just playing a squad with him dumb early
in the morning it was like 8:00 in the
morning and had to get one game in it's
the best time to play dude this guy
jumps on and his name's Chad Muska and
it's me and him and then like the
skateboarder that Doyle yeah but it's
not actually check ok they used to be my
idol when I was at the same moment 12 so
we were playing with these two young
kids and we know they're young cuz
immediately like as soon as we joined
like a pug si goat Chad Muska the e Chad
Muska
he goes you know it bro I'm like the
king of street he's like I'm here and
like we're like laughs circa shoes baby
yeah he had the drug pocket in the
tongue yeah that you own those shoes and
you never put weed and own everything we
just used to get off on the fact that
there was a drug pocket it felt so
badass
if we if we did do this stuff we could
hide it there well we don't because cuz
you don't probably swore that I would
never take a drug yeah you don't burn
and I do burn so you don't actually jury
still up so yeah and we were playing and
we were laughing in these kids like
who's Chad Muska
oh [ __ ] and we startled at the guy goes
ah goddamnit I laugh too and I'm like
well we gotta kill ourselves then we
like it just ended up playing duo's and
we played like a few games I said I
gotta get here man he's like all right
man cool nice playing am i yeah you too
and then that's it yeah and it's weirdly
personal how Fortin I can get and it's
also like it's not like you know people
are I guess the beginning a good
comparison would be the beginning of
Ober yeah they were like you're not
gonna get in a random person's car
mm-hmm what they could kill you yeah and
kidnap you yeah it's like no they're
just like you yeah what do you mean
they're just trying to make some money
drive people around yeah it's like
fortnight you know when I say oh yeah I
met this dude on four and I was a fan
whenever people oh that's so creepy what
are you gonna like make friends with
people line we're now man isn't Siva
front [ __ ] from counter-strike oh
yeah we knew each other counter-strike
yeah you guys are like best friends
they're like like lifelong friends
pretty much it's crazy since 16 yeah
yeah and I think that shit's just gonna
be way more common with four night yeah
but then eventually we'll get into the
part of fortnight where
you just want to join the squad and you
don't want anyone to talk yeah hey
what's up squad all right man yeah yeah
three stars I tell you please sir I'd
said that I talk on the podcast about
that guy which one that got me to help
him do his YouTube video I think so yeah
did I hear what the sex yeah yeah no
well I don't want to just think I meant
to say a few minutes ago was so a couple
dudes like a couple times I've been
recognized on fortnight so I never play
games like inebriated and I decided to
do it one night recently okay and I'm
like it's late thinking this should be
fine almost every game everyone
recognized me really and I was like not
in a state to be yeah talking like yeah
well I just got my voice cuz like real
charred and like raspy yeah yeah yes
good yeah
so I hold my bag oh my baby oh so hey
try this gaming it's these three young
kids this [ __ ] blew my mind the one kids
like oh my god dude oh my god other ones
like no way no way no way no way no way
oh my god dude please no way - all three
of them like they're buddies yeah and
then one was like a little bit older
than the other two
one of them's like you're a legend man
so I look at the map and one of them
dropped right out of the bus right away
okay you don't play for tonight he just
like he he did something ahead of the
team and so I thought they were calling
him a legend for like just dropping out
of the bus early so I'm just like zoned
out and then they just keep saying it
you're a legend man holy crap you're a
legend and I hadn't spoken the whole
time so I must have looked like an
[ __ ] then one of them finally goes
hey men do you watch that guy Cody Coast
Channel and I chuckle and I said oh are
you guys talking to me and they're like
dude you're awesome dude
it's super wholesome and I said I'm like
I'm like
I said oh man I didn't realize you guys
were talking to me I I would have I
would have talked sooner bro
imagine imagine being a kid playing a
game and literally of Chad Muska [ __ ]
signs on yeah not to say word Chad Muska
but I'm saying someone that you look up
to yeah as like a whatever yeah well
whoever made in whoever like that's
crazy this [ __ ] happens right now yeah
it is super crazy
then at muska signs out [ __ ] like
Tony Hawk pops into yeah you're just
bobbing your loan what yeah Tony
yeah what's good oh [ __ ] dude I'm so
hyper I'm so hyper right now oh [ __ ] I
left the game no I had one other guy who
oh this is the best part yeah I don't
even know I haven't brought this up it's
you know the end of your roast fans part
to the kid I roasted it looked like the
thing from Super Mario yeah
with the blockhead yeah so I'm in a game
here yeah this kid goes holy [ __ ] I'm
like what's up he's like no well I'm
like yeah he's like oh my like so
audibly nervous and my man I'm like I'm
just a regular guy don't worry about it
he's like dude no-ho-ho okay I have to
call my friend call my friend I have to
call my friend oh my god oh my god he
like can't he's fumbling real tough so
he's like well my friend I'm calling I'm
calling him right now he is at the end
of your video with Cody where you
roasted and that's like my best friend
I'm like oh [ __ ] so he calls him he gets
that kid on the phone and that that kid
was you know didn't care as much as it
yeah he's a youtuber gives a [ __ ] just
talking to me just supernormal yeah he's
been kind of mad but but yeah yeah he's
like me but I just got dissed the [ __ ]
out wait why are you calling it I won't
[ __ ] talk to this guy so I didn't
remember who he was so he calls him and
he gets him on the line I'm like what's
up man he's like dude you roasted me
this an animai cold on we pulled the
video I don't remember what you look
like and this is just [ __ ] classic
I get to his picture my oh your
blockheaded ass
and I started going in I was like
goddamn you probably put nails down with
that forehead [ __ ] forehead biggest
[ __ ] cuz I'm whatever I'm just I'm just
like I like flaming his ass and he's
like damn dude I was just I just wanted
to say what's up could you imagine like
yo snowy miller holy [ __ ]
hey dude love you but yeah you
blockheaded dumb [ __ ] sorry like
I talked to him for a few seconds and it
was super nice kids shout out to that
dude and you know so whatever we're
playing the game and then one kid goes
sorry man I don't know who you are and I
laugh I said you shouldn't know who I am
yeah I'm like I'm not someone you should
know yeah and then he like one of them
looks at my channel he goes oh [ __ ]
hundred fifty thousand subscribers bang
dude do you stream a lot and I'm like
laughing cuz that's the second time it's
happening where someone like searches my
streaming channel and I chuckle I go uh
if some kids like that's not his main
channel and I'm like and then he's like
whoa whoa you're waiting to flex that
[ __ ] I was just like this is what
brother why me
that's actually my second channel you
just got subscriber flags woo and you
know the other kids like what I do like
you're really this and that and I don't
know I guess to me I feel that when I
join a game it should feel that like I'm
just like a regular dude like you but
like what you're saying is like to some
of these people that really like what we
do it's a much different thing yeah it
is [ __ ] crazy I mean I was [ __ ]
fangirling a little bit like when I
played that dude Bret Phillips oh yeah
like the [ __ ] was in the it
like he's plays major-league base yeah
yeah he just DM he's like yo do one of
you wanna do is partner I heard you're
good yeah me yeah yeah I know that's
it's so cool man yeah when does that
ever happen before never never
then Kyle Tucker from the Astros he just
invited him yeah it was that was like a
weird flex yeah he was like he just
joins by the way [ __ ] is funny as [ __ ]
right Brett yeah yeah Brett yeah others
laugh is so funny Phillips he so we're
playing
for Nair whatever and just in the middle
of he's like yeah you want to squat with
some boys I'm like yeah he's like I for
sure hold up he's like okay tuck he's
like you you know Kyle I'm like oh no
he's like I plays for the Astros I'm
like and then I just like glance over at
my chat and see it was like Carl Tucker
Mike Strauss rose like just won the
World Series Stroh's you play yeah and I
start like freaking out I'm like yeah
these are like major [ __ ] athlete yet
so you know I love playing games with
the people who believe me yeah exactly
[Music]